with an increasing number of
heterogeneous services across cloud and
on-premises environments customers are
looking for consistency in connectivity
and security operations customers want
to be able to take a service centric
rather than infrastructure centric
approach to consuming cloud services
when consuming services some customers
wish to avoid exposure of their data to
the public Internet entirely because of
data security and policy requirements
introducing private service connect from
google cloud allowing you to connect
securely and effortlessly to Google
cloud services third-party partner
services and company owned applications
helping you to focus on consumption of
value-added services regardless of the
underlying infrastructure with private
service connect SAS providers can
deliver value-added services faster
providing a much better experience for
the customer consumers can access
services directly and privately over
Google's backbone network Google
operates an extensive private network
that insulates customer traffic from the
public Internet extending private
transit to the last mile for customers
who need or want this benefit private
service Connect creates service
endpoints in consumer V pcs that provide
private connectivity and policy
enforcement allowing you to easily
connect services across different
networks and organizations
services can be consumed directly in
your virtual networks without requiring
middleboxes
proxies or other complex configurations
simplifying the management of your cloud
architectures services consumed on
private service Connect have the same
high performance attributes as that of
traffic between virtual machines with
this product we provide you an
end-to-end means of connecting to and
managing services take advantage of
Google as a service centric Network
solution allowing you to reach and
satisfy your clients needs
private service Connect enables
customers to easily and securely access
services making it a win-win for both
producers and consumers visit us at
cloud.google.com
to learn more about getting private
access to your services today
[Music]